but uh yeah this was a big change for me
I never know how to pray I didn't know
what assembly was I didn't know what
Mass was so big shift and were you the
only kid like that were these kids
already assimilated or did you find some
kids where they they were like I don't
know what the going on either well it's
one of those high schools that started
in eth grade okay you know those ours
was ninth grade oh yeah oh yeah so they
already knew each other from that year
too exactly so I felt like the odd man
you know I'm not religious I I don't do
private this is all new and they knew
each other so it was a I almost shot the
school up you know I I was right there I
felt so out of place